all eyes will be on brie Larson this
Sunday the Best Actress nominee as
Oscars it girl but she has been a
red-carpet standout at every Awards Show
this season I mean it's been pretty
amazing to watch her couture game evolve
at ourselves here Josie got the secrets
behind it straight from breathe stylist
you know keep the shoulders back feel it
I love it
we literally tried on five dresses this
was the first dress we tried on and I
had just seen it in Paris the Sunday
before I didn't have a dress until I got
in at 6:00 a.m. this morning did you
have to get it altered or just fit you
perfectly we kind of wanted to close the
boob area a little bit because I'm a
little more modest than runway models
and there's a picture of you guys
working on the dress we are in the hotel
right next to the elevator
we like dominated their hallway we set
up basically like a table that's
literally those are sewing in a hotel
hallway we literally had three different
people sewing the details the best part
about breeze Oscar style transformation
is finding out the untold stories behind
each dress stylist Cristina Ehrlich used
this mood board of more than 20 photos
to help come up with Brees Golden Globe
gown Calvin Klein actually designed this
for me so they sent sketches and it was
just gorgeous I knew right away so this
is kind of the one and only when I was
the most blown away was when I saw this
beautiful gold thing that they had made
and to wear a dress that's that heavy
that's being supported by like a halter
neck it's a commitment here's a look
from the Oscars lunch which I loved what
about the eyelashes like I think people
were commenting saying that's so weird
it's so strange well we were like all
eyes on green I love that that's where
that came from
what my accessories are we were sitting
here with a room a floor full of shoes
and that's nothing nothing we cleaned it
up I was like they're not gonna be a
little walk in time what's interesting
is it's rare for breed to come meet
Christina in a showroom like this during
award show season and specifically for
SAG brie was on set in Australia
Christina had improvised I'm filming
King Kong I'm fighting my days running
around in the jungle
so she comes in she knows my body she
knows what I like she knows I'd like to
have fun bree is making King Kong how do
you guys even start to communicate to
get going you get on a plane and you fly
to Australia for 24 hours and we were
talking on FaceTime
we had some Skype fittings we just had
to keep the party moving breaking down
her fashion Bri is a fashion risk-taker
definitely eclectic but back in 2004 at
the prince and me premiere 14 year old
Bri styled herself but definitely had
hopes for more I mean you get people
designers or giving you clothes and
everyone wants you to wear their stuff I
think that it'd be awesome to be a
princess well more than a decade later
Brees style dreams and Oscar dreams are
finally coming true Christina dropped a
little hint of what we will see the best
actress front runner where this Sunday
the designer has been picked out since
December okay so he said Brees not
wearing black to the Oscars that may be
to an after-party maybe there is some
black in her future put it that way
right
there's perhaps some gold as an Oscar
gold so listen let's do some Oscar
fashion math right now notice that brie
Larson was shot arriving from London
even if she was actually shooting in
Australia so what is in London Alexander
McQueen where Sarah Burton McQueen's
creative director just showed her new
fall line with one possible Oscar dress
after another so I think right there AHA
a clue